welcome to this video playing troll bets
the one thing I played him before from
the UK so you have a name no no name ok
yeah I recently played the bloomenveldt
with some fun results let's try that
again I think it's taking nd6 what I
what I had looked at noe fall I think
it's the mains but it's been a while
since I've had a rough look at this it's
kind of a benoni now but with a quick b5
which you don't really get in so easily
in the Benoni on the other hand yeah
like that let us serve often just
hanging so need to be aware of that
there should be seven other ideas that
I'm threatening night takes d5 here so
this actually calls night BTW to bit
into question i think a 4 is the minith
but i'm not one hundred percent sure
about that ok so what about this is
peace just going here and care of course
only seven this is not ideal
you will probably play a form yeah I can
answer before it's not necessarily bad
hmmm not not sure maybe I should should
make sure that I get this Bishop
exchanged this is often a problem peace
and I get now I'll get the chance to to
exchange it yeah I need to play before
there's no big alternative it looks a
bit weird because I give up c4 but I
have known as mentioned nothing else
really ok take him I can no I take I
take that first
hmm well II five maybe my father can
probably take it's a bit a bit early 97
b6 something I can go a 5v5 would have
been been interesting I'd like to play
Knight b6 really to exchange it yeah
okay I e5 looks looks very dangerous I
cannot take I mean I don't think this
thesis may be still okay intending still
Knight b6 on e6 I go Knight b6 ok so now
night just might be six or what else
if i take yeah they do six move
get it out of the diagonal yeah it's not
very comfortable this position just
hoping it does something like is six and
not not sure that it leads to great play
iaff for Hank so he cannot even play 60
came if he takes Knight X I don't think
this is so terrible maybe maybe okay
interesting
yeah obviously this is hanging you can
take now a good Bishop f6 I hope this is
still some this is test alum somewhat
playable we wants to get the night there
okay cannot I cannot allow that now it's
still as the deep on that at least the
night only seven days a decent locating
piece
yeah of course I'm Lewis but how much
job maybe this isn't totally easy
I may be here to intend this andrew t 7
it's not very very nice d 797 maybe I
don't I don't see it yet but that's
probably a direct win I mean this is
probably very close to a direct one back
I could have played rookie one this is
of course not brilliant but it's not
it's not directly lost probably now that
is directly loss
hm
hmm my candy can just take c5 that's the
real problem
check-check time warning yeah it's not
much point in continuing rename check
check check yeah black resigns yeah this
simply wasn't a good position right out
of the opening just and it's just not
very good i mean not sure where to
improve i think this is the theoretical
line and a four is normal like I need to
I need some improvement here around here
Chan if one before it's probably this
this is more or less forced so maybe
Bishop g4 is really the problem
maybe 97 this is already already not
nice not nice anymore yeah I could have
played a 5 this would have been even
stronger but this uh this is bad enough
really round here it's really really
tricky 97 was possible as well here
rookie one was even stronger of course
here I wasn't I'm I must let c4 here I
must place afore at least try to get
some fight going something like that 9y
this of course still winning but this is
a tougher now gap that is just a win I'm
not quite sure a bit puzzled what should
I do here orbis should be seven is this
bad I mean it wins the tempo basically
so I don't think it can be so bad yeah
here maybe castles on maybe this is more
precise
yeah that looks like a bad benoni I mean
this has been played by some very strong
grandmasters it's not not a completely
completely terrible opening but I'm not
quite sure I don't know I'd ever saw
night pd2 but it's of course logical
enough or something else entirely
something radical I h6 g5 for something
something like that getting getting this
Bishop quickly ya ali at least the
sisters seems better than the game I
know it looks weird I mean an opening
which combines b5 and g5 is usually
suspect and not sure very tricky opening
ok thanks for watching